in my personal opinion
i believe that because of the second
amendment
anyone
should be allowed to keep and bear arms
and i said anyone
anyone now through due process you can
lose your right to keep and bear arms
that means if you're a convicted felon
due process has come and it's part of
the punishment you will you know lose
your right to keep in bear arms however
i personally believe that there should
be a time limit or a time frame set on
that meaning is it a life sentence is it
a five year prohibition we shouldn't
just say if you're a felon period it's a
life sentence to never defending
yourself i don't agree with that some
people commit felonies and they get one
year in prison and then they get out and
they go back to their lives they should
be allowed to vote and keep and bear
arms they can also get a felony for mail
fraud as opposed to a felony for an
assault with a deadly weapon right those
are different felonies what do you think
of an age
none because the constitution uh you
have to think back to
the time of the founding fathers muskets
regardless actually they had many things
they had locked pistols they had muskets
they had repeaters
eventually they had repeaters but they
also had um uh i forgot i forgot the gun
was called it was a multi-barreled gun
that could go up up up up up up up up up
up up up so they had fast firing
capabilities uh regardless
back then let me let me ask you a
question the year is 1770
and there's a farm
and uh the farmer has five children
ranging from 17 down to seven
do you do you think all of those
children will be working the farm
working the fields that seven-year-old
has a has a 22 or the equivalent thereof
in 1770 and he is trying to get rabbits
and and and pigeons and squirrels
because he's got to learn and he's got
to do his part and maybe not the
seven-year-old but maybe the 12 year old
is told by the father uh you know we got
a boar problem if you see him take the
musket and deal with it yeah very likely
the children were armed now there are
questions about population density and
how that impacts a lot of these laws in
my opinion but the constitution will
need to be amended
if we want to make those changes that is
to say i do believe it's reasonable to
have a to have an age limit to a certain
degree i believe it's reasonable however
the constitution does not does not
dictate this therefore i believe it is
unconstitutional to bar uh 16 17 year
old 15 14 13 12 whatever from bearing
arms my concern is that we've been
playing with age so much that now you
have to be 21 in in most states to smoke
not even just drinking to smoke in
virginia you have to be at least 21 for
a handgun yeah now that is crossing a
line i think anyone should say that's
wrong because you're 18 you can join the
military there was they want 16 year
olds to vote 15 year olds can drive so
it's like so you you can drive at 15 but
you can't but you can't smoke until
you're 18 but you can't have a beard so
you're 21 but you can go to fallujah
yeah at 7 00. but i think that's another
aspect another social aspect we should
talk about here is parents understanding
that they need to raise their children
to be smart responsible individuals and
not allowing us to be a subject and not
allowing the state or hollywood to do it
for them because when you do that you
teach people to be irresponsible there's
a huge problem with education in this
country and and i think a lot of the
fault is what parents saying i'm just
going to give my child to the to the
ipad to the tv to the state to the state
and i'm like that's one of the worst
things you could possibly do and i
really think if you you put on you know
a lot of personal responsibility on
people i think most people will of
course step up to the occasion take on
the personal responsibility give their
life purpose some people will win the
darwin awards yes but when it comes to
reducing harm i do believe reducing harm
in the long term is going to be the best
way by promoting responsibility rather
than dependent and people just relying
on the state i i think long term it's
going to help them i want to i want to
go back in time you see these photos
from the 50s or whatever of high school
gun clubs yes they're great if you raise
kids to respect and understand firearms
and firearm safety i believe we would
reduce uh violent violent crime would go
down right away because people are armed
and safe yes and accidents would go down
because kids would be well-versed and
well trained a lot of problems we hear
about with accidental shootings and kids
getting access to weapons is that their
parents hide the weapon from them and
don't train them in any safety but the
kid says i know where my dad hides his
gun and then not knowing anything about
it not being trained not getting any
safety protection or protocols
takes action and there's a stigma to it
and a lot of people in hollywood of
course every movie has guns and they're
all you know having all these action
scenes there's there's a huge
misconception there's so much
misunderstanding when it comes to
firearms and and just by making it this
kind of taboo topic where you can't
really talk about it you can't really
practice it you can't really have it
people of course naturally do want to
have it so what better way than to get
rid of all that get rid of all that
pressure and to allow people like like
you just mentioned in in schools
educate them about how to use it
properly because that is the only way to
really truly prevent harm not only were
they doing guns in the gun clubs in the
50s and 60s you've noticed how healthier
how much healthier you're ever going
i will say in my personal view if i was
the despot i would say
there should probably be at like age 14
a learner's permit for firearms and this
is when you can keep and bear long guns
and you can use it for school programs
and for hunting in the presence of a of
an adult at 16 you are legally allowed
as a human being to keep and bear arms
and defend yourself that being said
that's my personal opinion so long as
the second amendment exists
and it does not specify age then i
believe any law that seeks to curtail a
human right of bearing arms to defend
yourself is a violation of the
constitution so i don't agree i i
personally would not advocate for 12
year olds being armed i do think however
we need to legally lawfully
constitutionally address the second
amendment because it is broad it is very
broad the right to keep and bear him
shall not be infringed there's no age
restrictions in the constitution uh well
well there are i'm sorry that's that's
factually correct what i mean to say is
human rights if you want to run for
office it's 25 for congress it's 35 for
president i believe it's uh what is it
is it 25 percent as well or it could be
30 i think anyway 30 35 for president
yeah so what i'm saying is
kids have free speech
they do they have a right to free speech
so wouldn't they have a right to keep
and bear arms
a child can't you can't violate the
fourth amendment rights of a child
but the second
for some reason we allow this now here's
the problem i have with the age
restrictions
we say
okay then you got to be 18 to buy a
weapon we set that standard in law and
then 20 years goes by and they say okay
now it's 21.
so what in 10 more years they're going
to say 25 then 28 then 30 then 35 then
40 then 50 and then
we think it's reasonable that only a
mature adult of 50 years old should be
allowed to keep in bear arms no
it's either you want to argue 18 because
it's a threshold we have from minor to
you know adult
okay we'll argue for 18. i still think
the constitution when it was made they
did not expect 15 year olds to be
disarmed because 15 year olds were
fighting in wars and that's not a good
thing child
soldiers bad bad thing the point is i
think the founding fathers expected
people to be giving their kids weapons
to defend their property and their
country heck i think a half dozen
signers of the declaration were only
like 21 or 22 or something i mean i
think thomas jefferson was about 26 yeah
i mean they were they were all still
pretty much kids with the exception of
ben franklin right they were all they
were all there there were a few who are
like pretty old enough there but it was
a while there was a lot of a lot of
young 20 year olds um who were
considered wise and mature and i started
thinking about this because i was
watching the movie the patriot with mel
gibson and he literally hands his 10 and
12 year old sons muskets multiple
muskets how to reload and tells them to
fight in war and i'm like reload for
your brother that's right reload for
your brother while he's firing and then
he's providing cover and
you know i think any reasonable person
would be like kids fighting wars is a
very horrifying bad thing well look at
what we're doing with you know they talk
about kyle written as i tweeted this the
other day that a kid that age should not
be patrolling the streets with it with a
weapon of war that's the exact age of
people you want to send to syria and
afghanistan right in perpetuity to
patrol their their streets how many 18
year olds have we lost patrolling the
streets of fallujah
for their peace and quiet that's like he
shouldn't be doing it in kenosha you
know you know what i mean if you're
going to send them over to another
country and to maintain order
i admire the fact that he wanted to
maintain order for his own country i
think um
you know the defense in the written
house case is trying to get the gun
charge uh they tried to get it thrown
out i believe they tried to get thrown
out on because uh the the law in
question about
it is possession of a deadly weapon by
someone under the age of 18. but section
3c of the statute says that there's an
exception which then cites two other
provisions that you have to not be in
comply if you're not in compliance with
it you're exempted or something the
simple answer is it says it only applies
to people under the age of 16. i think
that makes sense that the wisconsin
legislature said no one under the age of
18 can have a weapon and then someone
was like what if it's my 16 or 17 year
old kid going hunting with me and they
went okay okay oh so then we'll put in
the exemption that specifically says
under the age of 16. the reason i think
that language makes sense is because
they wouldn't want to say a minor who's
under the age of 18 but we only really
need eight i mean ages 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen
so they basically said okay okay 16 and
17 are exempt
so i think that charge uh um i think
that should go to the jury
but i believe the judge has stated he
will instruct them not to read section
3c and the following provisions which
means they may actually convict him that
being said the defense should probably
raise a civil rights
question and file a lawsuit
over the charges um pertaining to as a
violation of the constitution they
should make the argument that the second
amendment does not uh specifically
grants the right to keep and bear arms
in general to all people ask the
question
do children have a right to free speech
and the courts have already ruled yes do
children have a right to be secure in
their possessions from unlawful search
and seizure the answer is yes
do the children do children have a right
to remain silent they do then they
certainly have a right to keep and bear
arms kyle right now should not be
criminally charged as a 17 year old of
all i mean come on we're talking about
12 year old about a 17 year old who had
a long gun
arguably with an exemption being
criminally charged over it make a
constitutional argument get to get the
law thrown out yeah
absolutely okay
i mean
it's it's just
i mean we're really we're reaching a
point where lawlessness is becoming the
new norm though so
we're we're living in a world where
certain laws don't apply to certain
people so when it comes to that aspect
we have a long wish list of things we
want but i think there's still a bigger
battle at hand there's still a lot of
issues we need to address in this
country when it comes to hypocrisy when
it comes to the political situation when
it comes to forces of the state being
used in order to do the opposite of what
is good for the people thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you